[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and at San Diego
comic-con we finally got a first look at
the Black Widow movie is it a bird is it
a tree
no it's Scarlett Johansson and the first
teaser from the film has a lot to unpack
from it throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the film and giving my
thoughts on what it could mean for the
future there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want anything from the
movie runed then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of the first look at Black
Widow okay so the footage opens with a
montage of all the previous appearances
of Black Widow in the MCU this covers
the entire catalog and it's crazy
looking back at just how much the
character has actually been in Johansson
then speaks over the top of the clips
and says I used to have nothing then I
got this job this family I was better
because of it I've made a mistake I
can't go back we then get an
establishing shot of Budapest which is
of course the infamous mission has been
named dropped in pretty much every
Marvel movie that Widow has appeared in
finally we get a clip of what could
happen in this mission
and widow walks into an old run-down
apartment with her gun drawn
she cautiously takes the corners and
then hears a voice say I know you're out
there to which she replies I know you
know so do you want to talk like
grown-ups this of course is the usual
back and forth banter that widow has
with her allies and after she turns a
corner she sees Yelena Bulova played by
Florence Pugh who also has a gun drawn
few questions if they are really
grown-ups and both refused to lower
their weapons they begin sparring and
both mirror one another and managed to
disarm the other so that they both end
up with the opposites gun they spar
again in the same outcome only this time
getting back their own weapons and then
a bigger fight between the two begins
widow uses a towel to smash Elena into
his sink and wraps it around her throat
and mouth to try and choke her from here
on out it's like a fight ripped straight
out over Jason Bourne movie with both
characters using whatever they can get
their hands on to defeat the other
Yelena grabs a knife and comes out
widowed but she blocks it and both end
up on the kitchen floor with each of
them
choking the other with a curtain they
both pass out and then we cut to Widow
pouring a drink and she says good to see
you too sis you just had to come to
Budapest didn't you from here we get a
montage of widow running through a
mountain range with agents chasing her a
motorcycle chase and finally Widow is in
a car at night that gets smashed into a
bridge the car is burning and she sees
something coming out there that looks
like a shape she tries to shoot it but
it blocks the bullets and the two have a
fight the shape completely mirrors her
moves perfectly and then a bowels to
reveal added it's in fact taskmaster and
he finally has her thus ends the footage
and now on to my thoughts honestly if
this is what we're in for it sounds
incredible and it's great to see that
it's going to be an all-out action movie
whilst I do think that taskmaster will
be set up as the initial villain a do
thing that eventually Yelena will be
revealed to be the one pulling the
strings and this is how taskmasters able
to mirror widow so perfectly as Yelena's
taught him a lot of her moves budapest
is obviously so devastating for widow as
it's the location she got heavily betray
that and ended up losing her
quote/unquote family only to regain it
with the avengers so i definitely think
that this is the aesthetic that they
would go with i'm really hype for what
could come down the line and if they
stick with this then i can really see
the movie being a huge success obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on this
first look and if you're excited for the
film comment below and let me know and
if you enjoy this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the Marvel phase four panel
which would be linked at the end you go
over all of the upcoming MCU movies so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more I'll leave that
linked at the end and hopefully I'll see
you over there after this I also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of Avengers endgame on
blu-ray to one lucky winner and all you
have to do is like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the Black Widow
footage in the comment section below the
one will be chosen at random on August
the 10th and the blu-ray will be shipped
out from then to ever gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like it's
scribe thanks again for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]